[Música]
lá
boa noite a todos a eac já andou de trem
da marina valle aquele trenzinho do
vinho lado de dentro o sol está esse
vale
bom a eu queria dizer pra vocês que nós
estamos um trem em movimento o trem do
rápido avanço da tecnologia e porque
usei a metáfora do trem pra dizer que a
gente está embarcado nesse tenha um
futuro ea outra tecnologia porque o trem
foi realmente nos últimos 150 anos uma
das maiores ferramentas da humanidade
pra abrir novas fronteiras abrir novos
mercados é é claro que diminuiu isso mas
nos últimos de 100 anos para trás o trem
foi fundamental para o avanço é da
humanidade para o avanço nos negócios e
refletindo sobre novas tecnologias ou
idéias que impactam gerações
três delas me ocorreram rapidamente 3 é
tão impactantes tão importantes que eu
acho que não impactarão apenas gerações
mais impactaram a humanidade como um
todo
falar um pouco dessas um pouquinho
voltar pra história há bastante tempo
atrás falar um pouco de história sempre
bom
a primeira criação a primeira invenção
primeira primeira coisa que eu queria
comentar é a prensa tipográfica de
guttemberg guttemberg trouxe a imprensa
não foi ele que inventou mas ele trouxe
a prensa tipográfica prensa de tipos
móveis e uma idéia criada na china mas
muito pouco utilizado até então o
tempero e trouxe para a alemanha a
europa no século 15 a prensa e ele mudou
o mundo a partir daí a partir da
presença de guttemberg textos e livros
puderem poderão ser impressos em larga
escala até então eram seis
viu nos filmes ou não vão lembrar porque
é muito antigo mas há os monges eles
copiavam os textos e escreveu os livros
à mão e isso vocês podem imaginar a
dificuldade das pessoas a aprenderem a
ler estudar
dessa forma com a prensa de gutenberg
isso terminou europa finalmente passou a
ser alfabetizada
muita coisa aconteceu por exemplo a
cisão da igreja católica se deu em
função justamente da prensa usada por
martinho lutero na alemanha martin
lutero começou a imprimir suas idéias e
divulgar pela alemanha e pela europa
toda isso provocou a cisão da igreja
bom a eu acredito que é claro que são
épocas completamente diferentes mas há a
ideia a criação uso dessa prensa é na
europa naquela época causou impacto
muito muito muito maior do que o impacto
provocado recentemente pelo uso maciço
com todos nós da internet
bom o segundo o segundo invenção a
segunda criação que o clube gostaria de
lembrar é a invenção de james watson
james mota criou a máquina a vapor e com
isso de novo mundo foi modificado porque
há a produção em larga escala foi
possível as fábricas como a gente
conhece hoje foram criadas a partir da
revolução industrial que nasceu em
função da máquina a vapor
james watson com isso veio a teoria da
administração com isso veio marketing
com isso veio o consumismo
pela primeira vez na história o homem
passou a produzir algo além da demanda
com isso ver o consumismo seja hoje nós
compramos que estamos dinheiro ganhamos
dinheiro compramos coisas que ele não
precisa
a maior parte das coisas a gente for
pensar um pouco a gente não precisa o
consumismo nasceu justamente do fato do
homem podem produzir mais do que a
demanda ea terceira invenção criação
novidade que eu queria a mostrar pra
vocês a aconteceu já muito mais perto da
nossa época em 1959 lover nós
em show um microchip ele desenvolveu o
microchip a partir de uma lâmina de
silício por isso ele passou a ser
conhecido como um fundador talvez do
silicon valley a o microchip ele
permitiu a a miniaturização de circuitos
eletrônicos portanto permitiu a produção
à criação de computadores e com isso é
robert na escola nós preocupa
proporcionou para nós é o o o revolução
digital pela qual a gente vem passando
até hoje nós continuamos no meio dos
tempos modernos dos tempos da revolução
a digital
a revolução de dólar e fazendo com que a
gente passe a viver de uma forma
completamente diferente do que a gente
vivia há muito pouco tempo atrás o final
do século 20 no final do século passado
nós passamos a nos deparar com
computadores a usar computadores
aplicativos softwares e dispositivos
móveis tudo isso fez com que o nosso
jeito de se compor com pelo nosso
comportamento mudasse a nossa forma de
comunicação da se enfim a nossa forma de
trabalhar e estudar a nossa forma de
consumir mudar se bastante é e o consumo
justamente o consumo a forma com que a
gente compra as coisas é a forma com que
o varejo trabalha isso foi uma das
coisas que mais foi mudada com o impacto
da revolução digital
eu tive a oportunidade de vivenciar isso
é com a construção da bematech empresa
que eu criei com o meu sócio roma e
depois mostrado nós no início da década
90 aqui em curitiba
criamos uma empresa para trabalhar
justamente em automação comercial
a bematech ela é e inovou ela construiu
ferramentas novas do varejo é interagir
com o consumidor é e e nós pudemos com a
bematech trazer para o brasil trazer pra
cá é novas tecnologias que foram criadas
na forma mas também criamos coisas novas
bom é a bematech ela ela teve um sucesso
grande é a partir justamente é é a
aplicação dessas novas tecnologias no
varejo é essa essas novidades essas
coisas novas que vêm acontecendo ela é
não pararam por aí
hoje nós a maioria de vocês conhece é o
supermercado amazon google que permite
com câmeras e com inteligência
artificial que é você possa é é
simplesmente fazer as compras e sair do
mercado sem pagar sem passar pelo check
out
outra inovação no varejo é o uso do
smartphone que vocês têm aí o o
smartphone hoje é capaz de ouvir as
conversas que vocês têm e com isso ele
passa a fazer push sou ele passa a
indicar coisas que vocês devem comprar
ou seja tomem cuidado com o que estão
falando porque o smartphone hoje ouvir
vocês e consegue indicar compras pra
vocês a partir do uso da inteligência
artificial de novas tecnologias
outra coisa que eu queria mostrar para
vocês eu passei de empreendedor para
investidor seja é a partir de 2010 eu me
aposentei da bematech passei a investir
em novos empreendedores de tecnologia
bom
um dos projetos nos quais eu investi foi
justamente um projecto a que trata de
inovação mas não mais no varejo e sim é
na sala de aula e nas salas de reunião
os nos escritórios hoje em dia a dia ter
uma água pra mim foi bom
obrigado
eu investi há cerca de cinco anos atrás
uma empresa de dublin empresa da irlanda
chamada hashtag rep ela é desenvolveu
ela já tem mais de 60 patentes no mundo
todo e ela desenvolveu uma nova
tecnologia touch não para telas pequenas
como do smartphone ou pra os tablets mas
ela desenvolveu uma tecnologia
multitouch para painéis gigantes para
telas imensas com essa que vocês têm de
aprender muito com ele decidisse dessa
sala com essa tecnologia da web com essa
novidade da rep
o google que adquiriu essa tecnologia
não adquiriu a empresa mas adquirir a
tecnologia o google ele é passou a
desenvolver ea usar como base pra novas
salas de reunião ou salas de aula a
esses painéis gigantes esses o haiti
borges gigantes que dispensam agora hoje
sou a caneta você usa o seu próprio dedo
ou uma caneta passiva para tocar na tela
e fazer desenhos e se comunicar com o
mundo todo ou seja é a base de uma nova
tecnologia que o google está criando é
de sala de reuniões de colaboração hoje
você já consegue usando de amor de
usando tecnologias a do google a
colaborar no mundo inteiro fazendo
reuniões com pessoas que estão na
austrália nos estados unidos na suécia
em curitiba como se essas pessoas
estivessem presentes na mesma sala ou
seja a percepção que se tem é que está
todo mundo no mesmo ambiente colaborando
s reunindo bom
além do de hamburgo com a tecnologia da
rep na qual investir
o google está desenvolvendo outras
ferramentas que estão dentro da sala de
reuniões
é como por exemplo o uso do google
duplex pra conduzir as reuniões que são
desenvolvidas ou seja o google duplex
ele já consegue hoje é organizar uma
reunião pautar uma reunião anotar os
temas discutidos na reunião anotações
que devem ser desenvolvidas a partir da
reunião e fazer
follow up para as pessoas que
participaram daquela reunião ou seja o
impacto disso o impacto disso vai
provocar a partir de agora o impacto
enorme impacto imenso bom é é um mundo
realmente já não é mais o que era há
muito pouco tempo atrás ele está mudando
muito rapidamente em função dessas
tecnologias todas falando ainda de
assistentes pessoais recentemente no
final do ano isso viralizou o google
duplex que esse assistente pessoal do
google ele é foi programado foi
orientado para fazer uma reserva de uma
mesa num restaurante em nova york ea
conversa foi gravada e por isso
finalizou
é uma conversa extremamente natural onde
o google duplex
ele conversa com o atendente do
restaurante e o atendente não tem a
mínima ideia do que ele está falando com
um assistente virtual
isso é causa um impacto muito grande e
eu fiz uma reflexão sobre isso e fico
pensando imagina a hora que do outro
lado no restaurante quem atendeu foi a
apple a apple se wii ou a amazon alexa
né
vai ser muito engraçado você perceber o
googleplex falando com é possível ou
daqui a pouco entra também na conversa
amazona alex amls passam a discutir
alguma questão que nos envolve ou seja o
meu assistente vai estar falando com o
seu assistente que vai estar falando com
a assistente daquela pessoa ltda marina
é engraçado interessante mas ao mesmo
tempo preocupante
ou seja o que que os nossos assistentes
vão estar mandando é em nosso nome né
outra situação interessante que eu
queria trazer aqui pra você imagine o
seguinte imagina que o meu assistente
pessoal ele a telefona para um colega de
trabalho é que me conhece
para marcar um churrasco para marcar um
jantar para marcar uma reunião
só que vamos um pouco além e imaginem
que esse assistente pessoal foi
programado por mim pra falar com a minha
voz
é ficção científica
isso aconteceu recentemente já é uma
empresa de tecnologia dos estados unidos
eles programaram um assistente pessoal
pra conversar com um amigo dessa pessoa
colega de trabalho ea pessoa que
conversou com o assistente pessoal com a
voz da pessoa original não sabia que era
um assistente pessoal
ele achava que estava conversando
realmente aquela pessoa de novo isso
aconteceu recentemente não é ficção
então a gente percebe que é os desafios
que a gente tem que enfrentar a partir
de agora são muito diferentes
profissionais pessoais dos desafios que
a gente enfrentava até pouco tempo
hoje já se ensina em escolas para
crianças conceitos de inteligência
artificial programação de computadores é
big data e coisas do gênero
isso não é só em são francisco eu estava
conversando aqui uma pessoa de ponta
grossa que tem uma escola que ensina
exatamente isso para as crianças forem
ponta grossa interior do paraná
aqui como é que a gente vai aprender a
se relacionar com um programa de
computador inteligente como é que a
gente vai aprender a se relacionar com
um computador com inteligência
artificial é existem já cursos sendo
dados justamente para tentar resolver
isso tentar melhorar essa situação em
dublin na irlanda existe um curso na
universidade de dublin a que chama se
justamente é como que o texto não sou
show saias que tenta resolver esse
problema tenta trabalhar esse problema
tenta ver como é que a gente vai
conseguir lidar com esse tipo de
tecnologia
as crianças estão aprendendo esse tipo
de coisa ou seja as pessoas leigos estão
aprendendo esse tipo de coisa não é para
se tornarem programadores de
computadores e engenheiros de computação
engenheiros de inteligência artificial
elas estão aprendendo isso pra poderem
lidar melhor com essas tecnologias que
estão vindo aí
para poderem utilizar justamente essas
tecnologias que estão vindo aí para
melhorar suas vidas suas atividades e
seu futuro vão precisar conviver com
esse tipo de coisa
queria voltar minha metáfora é original
do trem né
êêê fazer um desafio propor um desafio
pra vocês né
é o trem ele tem uma locomotiva e na
locomotiva esse é o trem da evolução
esse é o treino que vai pro futuro esse
é o treino do avanço tecnológico
esse trem ele tem uma locomotiva com os
maquinistas que estão determinando quais
os caminhos estão sendo trilhados
determinando a velocidade no trecho e
estão operando as várias variáveis que
existem pra você trilhar esse caminho do
futuro
nesse trecho existem pessoas como nós
estão confortavelmente sentadas curtindo
a viagem aproveitando essa viagem
acompanhando esse trem do futuro
porém existem algumas pessoas que estão
fora no trem pt ontem por ignorância
perderam tremtur atrás o pedreiro o
tempo simplesmente não sabiam que
deveriam pegar esse trem ea pergunta
final que eu coloco pra vocês aqui é em
qual desses três grupos vocês pretendem
estar de novo impacto dessas tecnologias
está aí e vai aumentar cada vez mais
eu tenho certeza que muitos dos que
estão aqui são maquinistas outros tantos
como eu estamos confortavelmente
sentados curtindo a viagem acompanhando
essa viagem do futuro mas eu espero que
não tenha ninguém aqui sentado no banco
dormindo e perdendo trem
obrigado
[Música]